pessoal cerca de 80% dos azeites ditos
Extra virgens disponíveis no mercado não
são necessariamente puros o azeite mais
saudável e fantástico paraa sua saúde é
o extra virgem porque ele é a variedade
menos processada extraída por métodos
naturais padronizado com alto grau de
Pureza e rico em antioxidantes esse
azeite de qualidade superior possui uma
personalidade única seu sabor e aromas
são distintos remetendo a frescura e
picância suave na parte posterior da
garganta Este é um sinal de
autenticidade é uma marca registrada do
verdadeiro azeite extravirgem que é rico
em fitonutrientes após um pouco de
experiência é possível sim você
identificar o falso apenas com simples
teste de olfato e Paladar ele não dá
essa leve cós enga na garganta e seu
cheiro pode ser mais próximo ao de um
óleo de cozinha comum Muitas vezes os
azeites são diluídos em óleos de menor
qualidade como de canola ou soja uma
mistura péssima de óleos compostos